Tyrel is even more gorgeous today
believe it about 22 years after she made
her first solo cover of Sports
Illustrated and every woman is loving
that the magazine with the veteran and
every woman wants to know what is her
secret an easy well it would help to
have her genetics that's a good first
step there retire also told me that it
helps to embrace your curse I was like
okay I'm gonna pull it together I'm
gonna get my body the same exact size
from 22 years ago and I started and I
was so focused and then I went to my
mom's house and there were some Cheetos
and then from there I just I just lost
my mind I was a 25 pounds 30 pounds
heavier than the cover twenty two years
ago when that swimsuit is smaller the
gushy stuff just looks so luscious kiss
I remember back when you had your talk
show and as you were hurt yeah by what
people were saying now you're
celebrating those curves how is your
relationship with your body changed I go
I'm human I still don't love to
cellulite on my butt don't like it but
it's not the end of the world at 45s
eyes new covergirl came out of
retirement after 13 years and has a new
fierce modeling name just banks that X
stands for X what you heard about what
Beauty means we are making a new rule
she changed the game in 97 becoming the
swimsuit issues first african-american
cover girl this year Tyra passed the
torch choosing s eyes first
african-american female photographer to
shoot her the pair had an aha moment in
the Bahamas all of a sudden she just
walks away from the camera I start to
cry yeah it was like a moment of light
and I was like
right and I just was like can you really
change somebody's life
the supermodel also got emotional when
we took her back to that very moment
that changed her life oh my gosh that is
crazy because I don't remember it that
girl had no idea
[Applause]
[Music]